we actually know very very little about
the dodo amazingly there is a vague
reference and this is probably one of
the origins of the name
that it made a sound like dude dude dude
hence dodo
i am dr vikash tataya conservation
director of the immersion wildlife
foundation my role currently is to
oversee all the conservation programs
that we have
on mauritius and these are conservation
programs for plants reptiles birds
and also education
the doodoo was a wonderful and animal uh
unique in many many respects
given the
transformation that took place from this
bird which was just a simple pigeon
when it started to become this
what people have called a grotesque bird
a very fat bird a very large bird with a
massive bill
we now know that it wasn't just hunting
that causes extinction it was also
degradation and loss of habitat but it
was above all the introduction of
predators such as cats rats monkeys pigs
because let's not forget the dodo
laid
a single egg on the ground
so it was an unprotected egg and it was
an unprotected chick
i meet the dodo everywhere and in every
day in fact when i get out of bed
i slip into dodo sandals so that's my
first daily encounter with the doodoo
uh i go into my kitchen and i'm and i'm
lighting uh my stove and that's with the
doodoo matchstick i'm wearing a t-shirt
which has got a dodo
insignia
there is a local economy that's built
around the doodoo
there are even
cast bronze statues wooden carvings it's
unlimited
there is a very very strong message
linked to the doodoo it was with the
dodo that mankind finally realized that
once something goes extinct it's forever
we would like
mauritius rather to be than being famous
for the extinction of the dodo it should
be famous for the savior of the
emersious kestrel of the pink pigeon of
the echo parakeet if i walked into a
forest and i saw a dodo it would mean a
dream come true a big challenge it would
mean rethinking the way that we do
conservation it would mean uh hope
for the rest of the world where they are
trying to revive
some of their species from low numbers
or even
rewilding of our whole places which has
been talked of so much in europe and
north america
and it would be quite a turning point
for conservation